[Musique]
dans les couloirs de l'hôpital
sainte-justine raisonner aujourd'hui de
telles notes
des musiciens de l orchestre symphonique
de montréal ont été re prêter des airs
du temps des fêtes pour le plus grand
plaisir des petits patients et de leurs
parents si on vient à l'hôpital environ
courant on venait inquiéter pour nos
enfants mais ça change comme ça c'est
bien tout à fait en fait aujourd'hui
vous avez été très anxieuse finalement
l'offre y est déjà un peu plus calmes
attirer son attention le concert de
l'eau et c'est ma sainte justine est une
tradition de noël l'an dernier la
pandémie avait empêché la tenue de
l'événement mais cette année même
masquer les musiciens tenait à offrir
des moments de réconfort et de douceur
c'était la première fois que maestro
rappelle paillard y dirige l orchestre
lors d'un événement de ce type et pour
lui pas de doute la musique peut aider à
guérir et traverser les épreuves avec la
musique hip hop hop offrir un petit de
pause entre petits d'espoir et de la
gloire mozart vivaldi pour jackson c'est
un petit cadeau de notre manière de
dirhams gracias merci
accompagné d'une douzaine de musiciens
il a offert un concert au personnel et
aux bénévoles de l'hôpital une pause
bien méritée et apprécié c'est très bel
exemple ça nous donne une motivation
continue notre bon métier notre approche
avec les enfants est chaleureux
infection c'est de la charente pour nous
comme on dit souvent ces petites
attentions le cndp est aussi ça nous
fait du bien
[Musique]
sortir des traditionnels salle de
concert pour aller à la rencontre des
gens et de rendez vous important pour
l'om qui désirent offrir la musique en
cadeau pense que la musique réduit bien
apporte de la sérénité alors revenir
dans un endroit comme ici les gens en
ont besoin et nous ici aussi en ont
besoin c'est très bon stimulant pour
aussi de penser que leur art leur musée
peut contribuer un peu de joie
l'espace d'un instant le public qui
assistait au concert à l'hôpital sainte
justine a oublié ses soucis unis par
l'amour de la musique est emporté par
l'énergie communicative de maestro
paillard et les soignants se sont même
transformés en chorale improvisée
des notes de douceur à la proche des
fêtes pour dire merci du coup rappelé
aux enfants et à leur famille qu'ils ne
sont pas seuls dans leur combat pour
retrouver la santé ici nabi alexandre
chartier radio canada montréal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]